bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 culture
au sommaire de ce numéro nous parlerons
particulièrement des journées du
patrimoine
madame elisabeth soeur de louis saez
posséder son domaine ils ouvrent
exceptionnellement et le découvriront
ces jardins ce week-end toujours dans le
cadre des journées du patrimoine la clé
des champs et du théâtre espace coluche
seront à découvrir
côté coulisses et un autre lieu à
visiter la maison de marthe à panne
l'artiste est notamment l'auteur de
sculptures présente sur billancourt
c'est une première pour le domaine de
madame elisabeth pour ces journées du
patrimoine
il loue ses portes au public des visites
seront proposées
la demeure elle sera à découvrir en se
glissant dans la peau d'un courtisan les
jardins eux le parc seront présentés par
les jardinets les images sont signés
florennes parfait
madame elisabeth aimé y passait ses
journées le domaine lui a été offert par
son frère le roi louis saez en 1783 une
demeure et un jardin rien que pour elle
entretenue aujourd'hui par cinq
jardiniers
c'est un domaine un petit peu
particulier à vous pouvez savoir qu'on
est à cinq minutes du durant château de
versailles
c'est un parc un petit peu intimiste on
est dans un écrin de verdure un type un
poumon vert au coeur de versailles le
papier à la française donc on est
vraiment autant louis xiv on est sur le
château de versailles des choses très
carré très stricte avec des bordures de
buis et là on est quelque chose on
s'ouvre à la nature 1 on arrive sur le
concept de jean jacques rousseau pour
aux pros de leurs auteurs nature et là
on va retrouver des perspectives ont
retrouvé des allées sinueuses 8 hectares
de terrains que le public pourra visiter
avec les jardinets une manière de
retracer l'histoire du jardin remaniée
au 19e siècle et de découvrir des
espaces insolites au détour d'une telle
elle de verdure vous allez pouvoir
cheminer jusqu'à la grotte musée pour
voir derrière moi et cette grotte un
petit peu magicien c'est une grotte qui
était créé autant d'aï la bête et des
condoms vous allez rentrer à l'intérieur
ça avec la sérénité le calme parfait
l'invitation à la promenade est lancé il
ne reste plus qu'à y répondre ce sont
souvent des lieux qu'on ne contenait que
du côté des spectateurs mais une salle
culturelle regorge d'endroits de lieux
où fourmillent un nombre impressionnant
d'acteurs du spectacle vivant
la commune de plaisir ouvre deux salles
le tec le théâtre espace coluche et la
clé des champs ils sont à découvrir sur
un circuit la visite commencera ici à la
clé des champs cette salle de spectacle
de 300 places s'adresse principalement
aux 16 30 ans à la base c'est une salle
de musiques actuelles dédié pour des
concerts mais il ya aussi des studios de
répétition qu'on peut voir derrière nous
ou en statistiques en moyenne vous avez
cinq groupes par semaines qui viennent
répéter ici de façon assez régulière
concert tremplin des voix ou jam session
avec le conservatoire la clé des champs
propose dix à quinze soirées chaque
saison à deux pas de là le tec le
théâtre espace coluche avec plus de 25
représentations la salle accueille
chaque saison près de 30000 spectateurs
ici le public découvrira principalement
la sensation d'être sur scène une des
anecdotes qui fait toujours rire
pourquoi pas deux
vert au théâtre pourquoi pas le mot je
ne dirais même pas ici c'est au rdr
voilà toutes ces petites choses qu'on
apprend qu'ils sont un peu la tradition
c'est vrai que maintenant c'est un peu
moins respectée mais ça reste la
tradition j'aurai le moyen de montrer au
public dépeindre la salle d'allumer le
plateau ce qu'on appelle en plein feu
pour qu'il se rende compte que quand on
a tous les projecteurs dans la figure on
ne voit plus le public on ne fait que le
ressentir côté cour côté jardin ou
travail en régie après ces journées du
patrimoine les salles plaisir oise
n'auront plus de secret il a été
inauguré en 1993 le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est une scène
nationale il propose chaque année près
de 140 représentations et le 17
septembre vous pourrez découvrir
l'architecturé du bâtiment mais aussi
les deux salles de spectacle les
coulisses ou encore les cintres elle a
inspiré le chorégraphe maurice béjart sa
perspective à guyancourt souligner les
liens entre la ville et la nature et ça
se voit au parc des sources de la bièvre
lc martha pâle une sculptrice hongroise
installé à saint rémy les chevreuse
jusqu'en 2008 la maison qu'elle occupait
avec son mari en grève orient ce qui est
à découvrir ou à redécouvrir lors des
journées du patrimoine une première
visite la maison conçue par andré vosges
ans qui trône au milieu des sculptures
des lignes droites de grandes baies
vitrées un mur noir et un atelier martha
pagny a dessiné et créé dès 1952 un la
sculpter ici une ses premières oeuvres
parfois de très grande dimension
je pense notamment aux sculptures dont
maurice béjart s'est emparé pour faire
pour créer deux ballets
et puis là effectivement travaillé
pendant une dizaine d'années ici à
travailler le bois à ce moment là ici
elle testait ses sculptures des oeuvres
flottante particularité de l'artiste une
prouesse rendue possible grâce à la
fibre de verre à partir de la fin des
années 60 elle en a créé une première
qui est dans un musée danvin dover amusé
en hollande
et puis ça l'a vraiment développer ce
type de d'intervention dans le paysage
et donc ses dix sont des objets que je
trouve absolument magnifique
exceptionnel de poésie parce qu il
finalement ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes
sur l'or ils vivent leur propre vie sur
des bassins la maison est à découvrir
sur inscription les visiteurs pourront
aussi flâner dans le jardin 18
sculptures en acier inoxydable créé dans
les années 1980 les attendent
on termine cette page journées du
patrimoine avec un autre lieu à
découvrir le centre national du cinéma
et de l'image animée
il est installé dans une ancienne
batterie militaire à bois d'arcy ses
collections représente près deux cents
mille titres qu'ils soient des fictions
ou documentaires des courts ou des longs
métrages et des visites seront proposées
elles seront commentés et ce sera le
samedi 17 septembre
on vous a présenté quelques lieux il y
en a de nombreux autres à découvrir ce
week-end certains d'entre eux se font
sur inscription n'hésitez pas à aller
sur le site des journées du patrimoine
dont l'adresse inscrite en bas de
l'écran on continue sur cette ut culture
avec la culture sur saint quentin en
yvelines
et si vous aimez les titres de jean
jacques goldman et michael jones le
concert proposé par arte beauty est pour
vous le guitariste franco gallois est le
premier artiste à se présenter à se
produire pour la toute jeune association
d'événementiel et c'est ce samedi 17
septembre là aussi à thoiry michael
jones interprétera les plus grands
titres du trio goldman michael jones et
fred et carole fredericks ainsi que de
nombreux titres de son dernier album on
écoute bénédicte rouxel elle est membre
de l'association et michael jones
l'artiste et après on écoute un extrait
sur le concert de michael qui était à
gif sur yvette
on a repris contact
sérieusement avec lui et on a commencé
un petit peu a discuté de et si tu
venais sur toi riches
il nous a dit pourquoi pas et dans ces
cas là comme on venait juste de monter
l'association
hong a demandé s'il voulait bien être le
parrain de notre association
donc c'est le premier gros concert pour
l'organisme la chaîne pour moi fut mon
bac à sable
c'est à dire que c'est là où je m'amuse
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté de faire
des sales gosses parce que j'ai envie
vraiment m'amuser et donc je ne fais tu
de la chaîne mais à partir de maintenant
et à
sans témoin
ça
quel départ mais
non
je vous en parlais la semaine dernière
les élèves du cours de peinture d'art
mural du conservatoire de montigny le
bretonneux participer au festival de
trompe l'oeil qui ont lieu qui a eu lieu
le 9 10 et 11 septembre il avait choisi
de rendre hommage aux cookies avec des
années 1930 1920 et pour cette fresque
qu'ils obtiennent le prix du public et
le troisième prix du jury le coup de
coeur de cette semaine c'est bertrand
pigné des yeux d'elsa à saint cyr
l'école qui nous le donne
il est question de western spaghetti de
sergio leone et d'hommes à l'harmonica
regardez le coup de coeur des yeux
d'elsa en cette fin de mois de septembre
s'est il était une fois dans l'ouest qui
ressort en copie restaurée le 28
septembre et que nous aurons nous en
avant-première de sa ressortie nationale
le 23 septembre pour une projection un
peu spécial que j'accompagnerai
on signe et conférences pour donner des
informations sur ce grand film ce
western à la fois classique
crépusculaire et évidemment spaghetti
comme on dit pour ses westerns italiens
alors évidemment tout le monde a des
images de ce film en tête charles
bronson
henry fonda l'homme à l'harmonica et c
to c grand motif c'est un film très long
qui prend son temps c'est un film
puissant qui a été vraiment qui marque
une moment fondateur dans l'histoire du
cinéma
c'était important pour nous de commencer
cette année avec avec ce film là puisque
c'est un grand film populaire et en même
temps une grande oeuvre de cinéma c'est
le démarrage de notre saison puisque on
commencera donc avec ce film là mais
ensuite on poursuivra nos actions lors
du mois du cinéma d'animation où on aura
une avant première du film la jeune
fille sans mains et puis on continuera
évidemment novembre avec le mois du doc
et puis on aura d'autres rendez vous
tout au long de l'année
le 23 septembre on se retrouve donc au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir dans sa copie restaurée en
version originale le film il était une
fois dans l'ouest de sergio leone
pour notre premier rendez vous on reste
avec il était une fois dans l'ouest à
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois on expose les affiches
de film réalisé par michel landi c'est
lui qui a raison
réalisée celle du film de sergio leone
il est aussi l'auteur des affiches de
paris brûle-t-il ou de tonnes camillo et
son travail est à découvrir jusqu'au 30
octobre
les lancements des saisons des salles
culturelles de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
continue les 23 et 24 septembre ce sera
au tour du théâtre espace coluche lady
valhalla interprète des chansons d'amour
du répertoire français
mais elles le font à leur sauce regardez
cet extrait qui la perd
et un dernier rendez vous à noter si
vous êtes plutôt musiques du monde le
festival d'île de france propose un
concert à port royal des champs à magny
les hameaux
le samedi 17 septembre regardez cet
extrait
le plus
cette culture est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
l'information continue sur tv fil 78